RIB-FAKIM
MAURITIUS
ITY
TEST TEST TEST, ONE, TWO,
THREE.
TESTING, TESTING, ONE, TWO,
THREE
TEST TEST TEST, ONE, TWO, ONE,
TWO, THREE, TEST TEST TEST TEST
TEST TEST TEST TEST
TEST
TEST TEST TEST TEST #
TEST.
TEST TEST TEST TEST TEST
TEST   TEST TEST TEST
TEST
TEST TEST TEST TEST TEST
WELCOME.
WELCOME TO THE COLUMBIA
WORLD LEADERS FORUM.
WE AT COLUMBIA ARE VERY
PRIVILEGED.
WE HAVE THE U.N. IN NEW YORK,
THE WORLD LEADERS COME AND THEN
THEY COME TO COLUMBIA, SO WE
ARE
PRIVILEGED TO HAVE LEADERS COME
TO NEW YORK ALL THE TIME.
COLUMBIA HAS THE LOCATION.
I'M A COLUMBIA GRADUATE MYSELF
AND I BELIEVE WE ARE THE
GREATEST UNIVERSITY IN THE
GREATEST CITY IN THE WORLD
I'M NOT EXAGGERATING.
SO BEFORE I INTRODUCE THE
SPEAKER.
AND I'VE HAD A DELIGHTFUL
CONVERSATION WITH HER, I WOULD
LIKE TO TELL YOU ABOUT
MAURITIUS.
I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT A FEW
POINTS.
IT'S A SMALL COUNTRY THAT HAS
BEEN SUCCESSFUL AND THE STORY
HAS NOT REALLY BEEN TOLD.
IT'S A STORY YOU SHOULD KNOW.
IT'S A STORY OF A COUNTRY THAT
HAS MANY  ACCOMPLISHMENTS SINCE
1969 SINCE IT BECAME
INDEPENDENT.
IT'S NOW A WORLD FINANCIAL
CENTER.
IT'S THE SECOND IN HUMAN
DEVELOPMENT, 15th IN THE WORLD
IN THE EASE OF DOING BUSINESS.
THOSE ARE THINGS TO BE VERY
PROUD OF.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE READ ABOUT
SINGAPORE, WE SHOULD ALSO BE
READING ABOUT MAURITIUS BECAUSE
IT ALSO HAS A WEALTH OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT NEED TO BE
TOLD.
IT IS CALLED THE PEARL OF THE
INDIAN OCEAN.
IT'S BEEN THE GATEWAY TO
INVESTMENT IN INDIA AND IT IS
SLOWLY, BUT STEADILY, EXPANDING
TO BE THE GATEWAY TO AFRICA.
WHY CAN'T IT ASPIRE TO THAT?
IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
IT IS FOCUSED ON EDUCATION
AMONG
OTHER THINGS.
IT HAS A VERY GOOD EDUCATED
WORK
FORCE
IT'S GOING TO BE IMPROVING
STILL
FURTHER AND THIS IS GOOD
FOUNDATION FOR PIVOTING TO
AFRICA WHICH WILL HAVE ONE
BILLION MORE PEOPLE BY 2050.
THAT MEANS IT NEEDS LEADERS AND
IT HAS IT.
MY OWN JOURNEY STARTED A FEW
YEARS AGO AS A BOARD MEMBER OF
MAURITIUS COMPANIES.
I WAS SO IMPRESSED I CREATED A
CAPSTONE PROGRAM SO WE DID
RESEARCH AS A FINANCIAL CENTER
IN THE WAKE OF THE PANAMA
PAPERS
WHICH RAISED A LOT OF ISSUES
ABOUT FINANCIAL CENTERS.
I WILL SAY THAT MAURITIUS IS
DOING VERY WELL.
I WOULD LIKE TO REEMPHASIZE THE
KEY FROM MY POINT IS THE PEOPLE
AND THE PEOPLE IS WELL
EDUCATION.
IN THIS REGARD, I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE THE PRESIDENT OF
MAURITIUS BECAUSE SHE SHOWS
THESE QUALITIES.
AMEENAH
AMEENAH FIRDAUS GURIB-FAKIM HAS
FOCUSEDDED ON WHAT I CONSIDER
THE MOST IMPORTANT FOCUS,
STUDENTS.
THEY ARE THE GENERATION.
THEY ARE THE FUTURE.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE, ALTHOUGH I
DENY IT ALL THE TIME, I HAVE
SOMETHING CALLED GRAY HAIR.
THAT USUALLY COMES WHEN YOU'RE
A
LITTLE OLDER, ALTHOUGH I'M
YOUNG
IT MEANS WE HAVE TO LEAVE A
LEGACY.
THAT IS WHAT SHE IS DOING.
SHE HAS FOCUSED -- THE HISTORY
OF AFRICA AND THE KNOWLEDGE OF
AFRICA ON WHAT THE BIODIVERSITY
WHICH IT HAS WHICH CAN BE THE
CURE FOR FUTURE
SHE'S CREATED A DATA BASE AND
DID THE ENTREPRENEURAL
SHE'S DONE IT ALL
SHE'S NOW PRESIDENT OF HER
COUNTRY
HER LIFE IS ONE OF
ACCOMPLISHMENT AND GIVING BACK
THAT IS SOMETHING TO BE PROUD
OF
AND SHE IS ALSO DEAR TO THE
HEART OF COLUMBIA.
SHE FOCUSED ON BIODIVERSITY,
CONSERVATION AND SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT.
WE KNOW WE LIKE THOSE TOPICS.
SO WITHOUT FURTHER ADIEU, I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY ONE MORE
THING
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT, RETHINKING
AFRICA'S FUTURE THROUGH
SCIENCE,
TECHNOLOGY AND INNOVATION.
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY IS NOT
SUFFICIENT, IT'S HOW YOU
INNOVATE IT.
ONLY IF YOU DO SOMETHING WITH
IT
DO YOU BRING PROGRESS AND IT'S
NOT JUST ON RETHINKING
MAURITIUS' FUTURE, IT'S
THINKING
AFRICA'S FUTURE, IT'S THINKING
FOR THE WHOLE WORLD
IT IS MY GREAT PLEASURE TO HAVE
THE PRESIDENT OF MAURITIUS TELL
US HOW MAURITIUS HAS DONE IT,
HOW IT'S DOING AND THEN WE'LL
HAVE A QUESTION AND ANSWER AND
I
HOPE YOU DO COLUMBIA PROUD BY
ASKING INSIGHTFUL QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, PROFESSOR.
FACULTIES, STUDENTS, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, GOOD MORNING.
IT IS A PLEASURE TO BE A GUEST
HERE AT YOUR WORLD-CLASS
INSTITUTION.
IT GIVES ME A CHANCE TO
RECIPROCATE THE RECENT VISIT OF
ONE OF YOUR OWN, A COLUMBIA LAW
STUDENT WHO CAME TO MAURITIUS
LAST SUMMER FOR RESEARCH ON HIS
CAPSTONE PROJECT.
SING DID A STUDY ON THE TAX
STRUCTURE OF MY COUNTRY LOOKING
AT THE ROLE THAT MAURITIUS
PLAYS
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF AFRICA.
I'M PLEASED TO REPORT THAT HIS
FINDINGS, AGAIN, SUBJECT TO A
DEBATE, IS FINANCIAL STANDING
IN
THE CONTINENT AND IN THE WORLD
AND HE SEEMS TO HAVE RETURNED
TO
NEW YORK A BIG FAN OF OUR
CUISINE AND OUR BEACHES, THOUGH
NOT NECESSARILY IN THAT ORDER.
MAURITIUS IS A TINY COUNTRY BUT
LIES 680-MILES OFF OF THE EAST
COAST OF AFRICA, YET, IT PLAYS
A
ROLE IN THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT
OF THE CONTINENT THROUGH A
SYSTEM OF BILATERAL AND TRADE
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN AFRICA AND
THE WORLD
OUR COMMITMENT TO TRANSPARENCY
AND CUTTING RED TAPE AS FAR AS
POSSIBLE NOW PLAYS AS NUMBER
ONE
IN AFRICA IN THE PROSPERITY
INDEX, ACCOUNTS FOR THE
BUSINESS, GOVERNOR'S, SAFETY
AND
SECURITY, SOCIAL FREEDOM AND
THE
NATIONAL ENVIRONMENT.
THESE CONDITIONS HAVE LAID THE
GROUND WORK FOR TECH AND
ECONOMIC EXPANSION WAS DRIVEN
WHICH GREW BY 5.6% LAST YEAR
AND
INFORMATION AND COMMUNICATION
TECHNOLOGY GREW BY 6-POINT 3%.
THE SUCCESS OF THESE SECTORS
PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE IN THE
ECONOMY OF MAURITIUS AND
MAURITIUS PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE
IN THE ECONOMY OF AFRICA.
THEIR PERFORMANCE UNDERSCORES
MY
BELIEF AS A SCIENTIST AND
ACADEMIC THAT THE SEPARATION
BETWEEN THE HAVES AND THE HAVE
NOTES ACROSS THE GLOBE IN YEARS
TO COME WILL BE DEFINED BY
INVESTMENT IN INNOVATION.
AFRICA STARTS AT A DEFICIT.
OUR CONTINENT IS HOME TO 15% OF
GLOBAL POPULATION BUT PRODUCES
ONLY 3% OF GLOBAL GDP WHILE
CARING 25% OF GLOBAL DISEASE
BURDEN.
AFRICA HAS 1.3% RESEARCH
SPENDING.
THE CHALLENGES ARE FUNDAMENTAL
STARTING WITH PUBLIC EDUCATION,
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL COMMUNITIES
WHICH TEND TO TEACH MORE THAN
CRITICAL THINKING.
ON A ECONOMIC LEVEL, WE ARE
DEPENDENT.
THIS IN TURNS DILUTES OUR
ABILITY TO SET OUR OWN AGENDA
AND TAKE CONTROL OF AND FULLY
PROFIT FROM OUR OWN ECONOMY.
THE ROLE OF GOVERNMENT IS
UNIQUE
IN ADDRESSING MAJOR DISEASE
PANDEMICS AND PREVENTING FUTURE
ONES
ONLY HAVE DIRECT ACCESS TO
FUNDING ACQUIRED TO ENSURE
PREPAREDNESS FOR PANDEMICS AS
WELL AS EBOLA.
AFRICAN UNION NATIONS PLEDGED
1%
TO RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT,
PART OF THE U.N.'S VISION FOR
AFRICA'S SUSTAINABLE GOALS.
THIS ROLE VALIDATES THE BELIEF
THAT INVESTMENT IN AFRICA, BY
AFRICA HERSELF IS ESSENTIAL TO
LONG-TERM PROSPERITY.
RESEARCH AND TARGETED RESEARCH
IS WHERE BIG ADVANCEMENTS ARE
MADE.
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES WHOSE
MISSION IS TO CREATE WEALTH BY
TREATING DISEASE, YET,
ADVANCEMENTS AGAINST DISEASE OR
DEPENDENT ON JUST THIS.
A STUDY REVEALED THAT OF 10
BROADLY USED CLINICAL
ADVANCEMENTS OF DISEASES 42% OF
THE CONCEPTUAL STEPS OF THE
TREATMENT --
SIMPLIFY, TOOLS DEVELOPMENTED
FROM STRUCTURING OF DNA ENABLED
GREAT UNDERSTANDING OF VIRUSES,
IMAGES IMPROVES DIAGNOSTICS
ALL OF THESE ADVANCEMENTS WERE
BASED ON UNTARGETTED RESEARCH.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THERE ARE
MANY SUCCESS STORIES IN AFRICA.
ALREADY, THE CONTINENT IS A
GLOBAL LEADER IN ADAPTING
MOBILE
PHONE TECHNOLOGY.
IN 2006, THERE WERE FEWER THAN
13 MILLION LANDLINES AND
130 MILLION SUBSCRIPTIONS TO
MOBILE PHONES IN AFRICA.
TODAY, OVER A BILLION PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS TO MOBILE PHONES
WHICH SERVE AS A PLATFORM FOR
THE DELIVERY OF SERVICES.
KENYA IS A MODEL USING
TECHNOLOGY TO PROVIDE
WIDESPREAD
SERVICES.
ILLUSTRATED OF THE THE ICONIC
IMAGES OF WARRIORS HOLDING
PHONES IN PLACES OF SPEARS,
OVER
90% OF THE PEOPLE HAVE A MOBILE
PHONE.
THE INSTRUCTION AND PENETRATION
OF MOBILE PHONES SET THE STAGE
TO DEVELOP A KENYAN PLATFORM.
90% OF KENYA HOMES USE IT AS A
VEHICLE TO BUY BANANAS TO
UTILITIES TO SOFTWARE.
IT IS BASED ON NOT AN
APPLICATION ADAPTED TO THE
LIMITED RESOURCES OF A
POPULATION WHERE 56% OF THOSE
DEVICES ARE PHONES
THE RESULT OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
IS
THAT 66% OF THE KENYAN
POPULATION IS NOW BANKED
COMPARED TO 20% A DECADE AGO
AND
EXCEEDING THE GLOBAL OUTRAGE.
$28 BILLION OF GOODS AND
SERVICES WENT THROUGH, COMPARED
TO 44%.
THIS MAKES KENYA FIRST IN THE
WORLD NOT JUST ON THE CONTINENT
IN THE PENETRATION OF MOBILE
MONEY TRANSFER TECHNOLOGY.
THIS TRADE BODY CLAIMS THAT FOR
EVERY 10% INCREASE IN PHONE
PENETRATION, PRODUCTIVITY
IMPROVES BY 4% AND DOUBLING
MOBILE DATA USAGE INCREASES.
AFRICA IS IN POSITION TO LEAD
ENTREPRENEUR SHIP TO THE  HOME
OF
THE POPULATION.
IN THE TEN YOUNGEST AFRICAN
COUNTRIES, THE MEDIAN AGE IS
14-18.
BY 2034, AFRICA WILL BE HOME TO
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF WORKING
AGE ADULTS
THE WORLD BANK ESTIMATES THAT
THIS COULD GENERATE 11-15%
GROWTH OVER THE NEXT 20 YEARS.
THE ENERGY IS EMERGING FROM
TECHNOLOGY IN CITIES THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY.
VENTURE CAPITAL FUNDING OF TECH
START-UPS INCREASE BY A FACTOR
OF 10 IN TWO YEARS FROM
$41 MILLION IN 2014 TO
440 MILLION IN 2014 AND
PROJECTED TO REACH 600 MILLION
BY NEXT YEAR.
ONE FACTOR THAT POSITIONS US TO
SUCCEED IS THAT IN MANY
INDUSTRIES, WE HAVE LITTLE OR
NO
LEGACY.
THIS RELATIVE LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE MEANS LITTLE
RESISTANCE FOR US TO LEAPFROG.
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR INNOVATIONS
FROM BIODIVERSITY AND LIVE
SINCES.
THIS IS THE PREMISES OF THIS
ORGANIZATION.
IT WILL BE AN IMPORTANT DRIVER
OF AFRICAN SIGNS IN THE COMING
YEARS.
WITH SEED FUNDING FROM THE
WELCOME TRUST, THE BILL AND
LINDA GATES FOUNDATION, IT IS
BASED ON THE PREMISE THAT WORLD
CLASS AFRICA SCIENCE INVASION
WILL BE LEAD BY AFRICANS IN
AFRICA, BY AFRICA, FOR AFRICA.
IT IS GATHERING PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE INVESTMENT TO BUILD A
STRUCTURE FOR SCIENCE AND
ADVOCATES FOR THE CONDITIONS TO
CLAIM THE RIGHTFUL PLACE AS A
GLOBAL DRIVER OF PROSPERITY.
EVERY STEP IN THE RESEARCH
LATTER MUST BE REENFORCED.
WORLD-CLASS FELLOWSHIPS IN
AFRICA ARE UNEXISTING FORCING
OTHERS TO TRAIN OVERSEAS
MANY NEVER RETURN
PROFESSIONALLY
WHICH IS THEIR LOSS AND
AFRICA'S
LOSS.
AFRICA RESEARCH MUST SET UP A
CYCLE WHO CAN IN TURN PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO GRADUATE STUDENTS
AND POST OPS.
OUR WELL BEING IS CRITICAL ON
HOW WE MANAGE CLIMATE CHANGE.
CHOICES AT THE CROSSROADS OF
THE
ECONOMY.
THE ECONOMIC MODELING OF
CLIMATE
CHANGE PREDICTS A AVERAGE
GLOBAL
TEMPERATURE RISE OF 1.5-DEGREE
BY 2040 WITH COSTS EQUIVALENT
TO
1.7% OF AFRICA.
ECONOMIC COSTS INCREASE TO THE
EQUIVALENT OF 3-POINT 4%.
BY THE END OF THE COUNTRY, WITH
A TEMPERATURE RISE OF
4.1 DEGREES, THE ECONOMIC COSTS
ARE EQUIVALENT TO JUST UNDER
10%.
WE MUST LOOK BEYOND AND THE
INDUSTRIES TO DEVELOP RENEWABLE
RESOURCES TO CURB CLIMATE
CHANGE
AND ASSURE SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT.
THINK ABOUT THE POTENTIAL OF
OUR
OCEANS AS A SOURCE OF FOOD AND
ENERGY.
THE OCEANS ARE HOME TO ABOUT
2 MILLION SPECIES FROM THE
LARGEST ANIMAL WHO HAS EVER
LIVED TO THE  -- OCEANS COVER
71% OF
OUR PLANET'S SURFACE AND OUR
LIFE SUPPORT SYSTEM FOR EARTH
AND PROVIDE MORE THAN HALF OF
THE OXYGEN WE BREATHE
THEY ARE ESSENTIAL IN THE CYCLE
THAT PRODUCES RAIN AND SNOW AND
NOURISHES ONE BILLION PEOPLE
WITH ANIMAL PROTEIN.
THE OCEANS REGULATE THE GLOBAL
CLIMATE, MEDIATE TEMPERATURES
AND DRIVE THE WEATHER,
DETERMINING RAINFALL, DROUGHTS
AND THEY ARE A STORE OF CARBON.
84% IS CIRCULATED THROUGH
MARINE
WATERS
AFRICA IS A SOURCE OF NATURAL
WEALTH.
CONSERVING IS CRITICAL.
WHEN THIS RESOURCE IS
CONSERVED,
FARMERS AND SCIENTISTS USE IT
TO
ADAPT CHALLENGES DOWN THE ROAD.
OUR REMAINING GAUGE WITH THIS
CONVERSATION WITH THE FOOD
FOREVER INITIATIVE AS THE
DIVERSITY OF CROPS AND
LIVESTOCKS ARE FUNDAMENTAL TO
CHALLENGES.
A RELATIVELY LACK OF OIL AND
MINERAL RESOURCES COMPARED TO
OTHER COUNTRIES.
I WROTE AN ARTICLE TO
UNDERSCORE
HOW OUR PLANTS AND ANIMALS CAN
BE A SOURCE OF HUMAN AND
FINANCIAL DIVIDENDS.
60% OF COMMERCIAL AVAILABLE
DRUGS ARE BASED ON MOLECULES
DERIVED FROM PLANTS.
ABOUT 25% OF ALL PLANTS RESIDE
IN AFRICA, JUST 83 OF THE 11
PLANT DERIVED DRUGS MARKETED
GLOBALLY ARE FROM AFRICAN
SPECIES.
ON OUR PLANET, PLANTS ARE
UNEXPLORED AND AFRICAN SPECIES
ARE DISAPPEARING DRIVEN BY
CLIMATE CHANGE AND DEVELOPMENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, MAURITIUS
BY ANY STANDARD IS TINY, EVEN
THOUGH MAURITIUS AND NEAR BY
ISLANDS ARE HOT SPOTS, ALMOST
100 SPECIES HAVE BECOME EXTINCT
AND ONLY 2% OF OUR FOREST
REMAIN.
YET, WITH THE RIGHT PRIORITIES,
SMALL COUNTRIES CAN PUNCH ABOVE
THE WAIST
IF DEVELOPMENT IS NECESSARY BUT
NOT SUFFICIENT, IT REQUIRES THE
RIGHT TECHNICAL LEGAL AND
CULTURE CONDITIONS TO ENCOURAGE
RESEARCH INVESTMENT.
I HAVE FOUND THE CENTER, WHICH
SEARCHES FOR INGREDIENTS FROM
OUR LOCAL SPECIES FOR POTENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT.
WHILE AFRICAN NATIONS ARE RICH
AND A GROWING SOURCE, HOME TO 6
OF THE TOP 10 GLOBAL
DISCOVERIES
OF OIL AND GAS IN 2013, SOURCES
OF ENERGY ARE ESSENTIAL FOR
SUSTAINED AFRICAN ECONOMY.
AN EXTRACT OF A PLANT, LONG
USED
BY THE SAND PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
EXPLORED AS AN APPETITE
SUPPRESSANT.
OTHERS ARE USED COMMERCIALLY IN
SKIN AND BEAUTY PRODUCTS
OUR NATURAL WORLD HAS INSPIRED
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS USING
VERTICAL HALLERS IMITATING INCH
WORMS, DEVELOPED RESEARCH AND
RESCUE AND LIMBS MODEL
TENTACLES
ALL OF THESE ARE LEVERAGE MORE
CRITICAL AS THE POINT KNOWN AS
THE VALLEY OF DEATH.
AT THIS JUNCTURE, RESOURCES ARE
NECESSARY TO OVERCOME THE
RESEARCH, ECONOMIC, CLINICAL,
LEGAL AND OTHER BARRIERS TO
DRUG
DEVELOPMENT SUCH AS CONTAINING
THE EBOLA OUTBREAK BEFORE IT
BECAME A GLOBAL SCOURGE.
ADDRESSING THESE THINGS, WE SIT
-- IN THE BROADER CONTEXT OF
NUTRITION, HEALTH, AGRICULTURE
AND THE ECONOMY.
IT REQUIRES SUSTAINED FUNDING
AND CAPITAL SUPPORT AND THE
CAPACITY TO ENGAGE WITH
POLICYMAKERS, COMMUNITIES AND
OTHER STAKE HOLDERS
ONLY SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
ALL OF THESE ELEMENTS,
PRIVATE-PUBLIC INVESTMENT,
EXPLOITING RESOURCES, CREATING
THE POLICY CONDITIONS TO
ENCOURAGE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION OF SCIENTISTS HERE
ON
THE CONTINENT WILL CREATE A
SUSTAINABLE RESEARCH THAT LEADS
TO LESS DISEASE, MORE
PROSPERITY
AND MORE INSPECT  INDEPENDENCE
IN AFRICA.
THE CHALLENGE IS NOT EASY.
REACHING DEPENDS ON
CONTRIBUTION
ON AMBITIOUS INITIATIVES.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, IT CAN BE
DONE BECAUSE IT MUST BE DONE.
OUR ABILITY TO CREATE A
SUSTAINED FUTURE FOR OURSELF IS
POSSIBLE
THERE'S AN AFRICAN PROVERB SAYS
THE BEST TIME TO PLANT A TREE
IS
20 YEARS AGO, THE SECOND BEST
TIME IS NOW.
BRING YOUR SEEDLINGS AND WE'LL
PLANT TOGETHER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
>> NOW YOU CAN SEE WHY I FELL
IN
LOVE WITH MAURITIUS WHEN I
WENT.
LOTS OF FOOD FOR THOUGHT.
AND IT'S CLEAR THAT SMALL
COUNTRIES LIKE MAURITIUS REALLY
PUNCH ABOVE THEIR WEIGHT, THEY
HAVE THINGS TO SAY, WE HAVE
THINGS TO LEARN.
THANK YOU.
WE ARE NOW OPEN FOR QUESTIONS.
COLUMBIA IS KNOWN FOR GOOD
QUESTIONS
THERE'S A MIC ON EACH SIDE IF
YOU WOULD STAND UP, GET ONLINE,
AND WHEN I CALL UPON YOU FOR
THE
QUESTIONS, PLEASE, GIVE YOUR
NAME, YOUR COLUMBIA AFFILIATION
AND OBVIOUSLY THE QUESTION IS
NOT TO ME, BUT TO HER.
WHILE YOU'RE LINING UP, I WILL
ASK A MINOR QUESTION TO GET THE
BALL ROLLING.
YOU HAVE GIVEN PERSPECTIVE OF
WHERE AFRICA IS FOR POTENTIAL
AND HOW IT NEEDS TO BE PART OF
THE WORLD AND NEEDS TO DO MORE
RESEARCH, CAN YOU GIVE US JUST
AN IDEA OF WHERE WILL MAURITIUS
BE WITHIN THAT SPHERE 25 YEARS
FROM NOW OR 50 YEARS FROM NOW.
WHAT'S YOUR VISION?
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT
REFLECTION.
IN FACT, THIS IS THE QUESTION
THAT GETS ASKED TO COUNTRIES
WHICH ARE PROCEEDING.
AT THE SAME TIME, IT'S A
REFLECTION THAT MAKES US THINK
WHERE WE WANT TO BE.
IS THE BENCHMARK GOING TO BE
ONLY PER CAPITA INCOME OR IS
THE
BENCHMARK GOING TO BE CREATING
FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE?
IT WILL LEAD TO THE PER CAPITA
INCOME
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS LOOK AT
OUR STRENGTH, THE WEAKNESSES,
AND SEE WHAT IS THE STRENGTH.
I CAN SAY NOW THAT THIS
REFLECTION SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DONE
YESTERDAY SO WE CAN BETTER
POSITION OURSELVES.
I THINK OUR STRENGTH WOULD BE
IN
THREE SECTORS, THE GREEN, THE
BLUE, AND THE WHITE ECONOMIES.
THE WHITE I WOULD SAY IS A
SERVICES
I THINK WE'RE DOING QUITE WELL
THERE.
WE NEED TO DEVELOP THE
INNOVATION SPACE, WE NEED THE
SCIENCE, TECHNOLOGY SPACE AND
THIS CAN BE DONE WHERE WE'RE
STRONG.
WE ARE A DIVERSITY HOT SPOT AND
WE HAVE PLENTY OF GREEN
MATERIAL
TO GENERATE THESE STEPS SO WE
CREATE JOBS ALSO FOR OUR YOUTH.
ONE THING TO BE MINDFUL OF,
AFRICA IS A YOUNG COUNTRY, WITH
I NEED TO CREATE JOBS
WE NEED TO CREATE A CONTINENT
OF
ENTREPRENEURS AND THIS CAN ONLY
BE DONE WHEN WE START THE
PROCESS NOW OR YESTERDAY.
HAVING SAID THIS, OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO CREATE
STRONG INSTITUTIONS
I AM HERE TODAY.
COLUMBIA HAS A FANTASTIC
REPUTATION BECAUSE THIS
GOD-GIVEN INSTITUTIONS, THEY
HAVE APPOINTED GUARDIANS TO
PRESERVE THE REPUTATION OF THIS
PLACE AND WHEN WE LEAVE THIS
PLACE, IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO LEAVE IT WITH STRONGER
INSTITUTION THAN WHEN WE FOUND
IT.
>> THANK YOU PRESIDENT FOR
COMING AND SPEAKING TODAY.
I WAS VERY IMPRESSED BY THE
DEDICATION TO RESEARCH
ESPECIALLY CRITICAL FUNDING TO
RESEARCH AND BIODIVERSITY AS
WELL
I WAS WONDERING IN THE NEXT FEW
DECADES, WHAT DO YOU SEE FOR
THE
ROLE OF ARTISTS AND SCIENTISTS
WORKING TOGETHER.
HOW WILL THE ARTISTS AND
WRITERS
WORK ALONGSIDE AND BRING A
COUNTRY LIKE MAURITIUS TO ITS
FOREFRONT AND WHAT DO YOU SEE
AS
POTENTIALS AND A SMALL SIDE
NOTE, WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE
MAURITIUS ARTIST OR WRITER?
>> THANK YOU.
I JUST READ RECENTLY SOMEBODY
LIKE CHARLES DARWIN AND EVEN
GREAT SCIENTISTS LIKE NEWTON,
THEY WERE READING POETRY.
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS USE
CULTURE ALSO AS A SOURCE OF
INNOVATION AND I HOSTED A
CONFERENCE AT THE STATE HOUSE
WHERE I BROUGHT PEOPLE FROM THE
WALKS OF ART, NATURE, AND
SCIENCE AND PUT THEM TOGETHER
AND IT WAS IMPRESSIVE TO SEE
THE
THINKING YOU CAN GET.
I THINK THAT CULTURE AND ART
WOULD BE PART OF THIS WHOLE
DYNAMICS, IF WE WANT TO ENSURE
CREATIVITY, CRITICAL THINKING,
IT COMES FROM AN ARTIST
VIEWPOINT, TOGETHER, WE CAN
MAKE
IT BIGGER.
I THINK THIS IS A SPACE WHERE I
FIND THAT THE FAMOUS ADDITION
OF
1 PLUS 1 GIVES 3.
MY ARTISTS, QUITE A FEW.
I WILL NOT MENTION THOSE
LIVING,
IT MAY CREATE SOME JEALOUSY,
BUT
IN THE PAST WE HAD GREAT
PEOPLE,
THESE ARE THE BIG NAMES IN MY
COUNTRY.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR REMARKS
MY NAME IS MARK, I'M STUDYING
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS
I WORKED IN EAST AFRICA AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND I SAW
THAT ISSUES WITH CORRUPTION
COULD BE RESTRICTIVE, I'M
CURIOUS FROM A LEADER'S
PERSPECTIVE HOW INNOVATION CAN
BOOST AND BATTLE SOME OF THE
FORCES LIKE CORRUPTION
RESTRICTING SOME OF THE
ECONOMIES.
>> THE ANSWER IS IN YOUR
QUESTION, WITH THE TECHNOLOGY,
WITH THE ADOPTION OF
TECHNOLOGY,
IN MY GOVERNMENT DEPARTMENTS,
WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO TACKLE NOT
ONLY THE RIGHT TAPE BUT THE
CORRUPTION.
THIS IS AGAIN SOMETHING WHERE
MAURITIUS IS MOVING.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE REVENUE
AUTHORITY, IT'S ESSENTIALLY
DIGITAL AND WE ALSO USE THE
SAME
APPROACH FOR ACQUIRING PERMIT.
IT'S WHERE THERE CAN BE
CORRUPTION.
USING TECHNOLOGY FOR THE
BETTERMENT OF THE FUNCTIONING
OF
INSTITUTION, THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT TECHNOLOGY HAS A BIG PLACE
TO PLAY.
>> JUST WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SPEECH.
AS A FELLOW MAURITIUS, IT'S A
PLEASURE.
MY QUESTION CONCERNS AN ISSUE
FOR THE COUNTRY.
I'M CURIOUS ABOUT WHAT IS THE
BIGGEST INCENTIVE FOR THOSE
STUDYING ABROAD TO COME BACK TO
THE COUNTRY?
>> I ASKED THE SAME QUESTION
ALMOST 30 YEARS AGO WHEN I
FINISHED MY STUDIES.
THE DEBATE WAS WHETHER I SHOULD
COME TO THE U.S.
I WAS OFFERED A POST DOC HERE
OR
GO BACK.
I WENT BACK.
I THINK YOU KNOW NOW WE ARE
WHERE WE CANNOT SAY WE HAVE TO
OPERATE FOR BRAIN GAME.
WE HAVE TO OPERATE IN THE
SCENARIO, IN MAURITIUS IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE MAURITIUS TO
CONTRIBUTE TO MAURITIUS.
THEY CAN BE ELSEWHERE.
WITH  THE POWER OF TECHNOLOGY,
WE
CAN LEVERAGE ALL OF THIS TALENT
INTO WHAT WE CAN DO IN
MAURITIUS.
I THINK ALSO IF WE WANT TO GO
TOWARD THE BRAIN GAIN, THE WAY
MOST PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IT, IT'S THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
LEADERS IN COUNTRY TO CREATE A
SYSTEM WHICH IS FAR BETTER THAN
WHAT YOU ARE GETTING HERE.
IT MAY SEEM LIKE A LOFTY IDEA
THAT I'M COMING UP WITH.
THIS HAS BEEN THE SCENARIO IN
CHINA, THIS HAS BEEN THE
SCENARIO IN INDIA, TO SAY IF WE
WANT TO ATTRACT THEM BACK, WE
HAVE TO GIVE THEM THE TOOLS TO
FLOURISH.
THIS IS THE REASON WHY IT HAS
PUSHED ME TO DO THIS.
BUILD A SYSTEM IN THE
RESPECTIVE
COUNTRIES WHERE THE PROBLEMS
ARE
SO WITH I CAN GET TO TALENTS TO
COME BACK.
AT LEAST FROM THAT POINT THEY
WILL COME AND SHARE THEIR
EXPERTISE AND TALENTS.
YOUR LOSS BY NOT COMING TO
MAURITIUS AND OUR LOSS FOR NOT
HAVING YOU THERE.
>> THANK YOU.
I'M REALLY EXCITED TO LISTEN TO
YOUR REMARKS TODAY.
I'M CURRENTLY AN UNDERGRADUATE
FRESHMAN STUDYING BIOCHEMISTRY
I'M INTERESTED ABOUT THE
RESEARCH.
THE FIRST IS HOW IS MAURITIUS
BALANCING THE FUNDAMENTAL
SCIENCE RESEARCH WHICH MAY HAVE
POTENTIAL OF THE FUTURE AND
TECHNOLOGY DRIVEN INDUSTRY
LEADER RESEARCH WHICH MAY HAVE
POTENTIAL TODAY.
AND SECOND QUESTION IS ABOUT
THE
PROCESS.
YOU MENTIONED THAT MAURITIUS IS
ENCOURAGING SCIENTISTS AND
ENTREPRENEUR STUDENTS ON EBOLA
RESEARCH AND SOME KINDS OF
CANCER, HOW IS MAURITIUS
ENCOURAGING THE PROCESS TO
CONVERT IN THE LABORATORY TO A
CLINICAL OPERATION IN MARKET?
THANK YOU.
>> LIKE I JUST MENTIONED IN THE
SPEECH, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
CULPRIT, A BIG PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANY, IT'S NOT IN THE
BUSINESS PLAN TO ENCOURAGE THIS
RESEARCH, WHICH IS THE BASICS .
THIS IS A RESPONSIBILITY FOR
GOVERNMENT TO INVEST IN THAT
SPACE.
IT'S A CHALLENGE.
WHEN THERE'S NOT THE VISION,
THE
BLUEPRINT AS TO WHERE WE WANT
TO
GO IN 50 YEARS TIME, IT IS
DIFFICULT TO KNOW WHERE WE'RE
GOING BECAUSE WE WILL NOT GET
THE PROPER COMMITMENTS
YOU NEED TO HAVE A PLAN, YOU
CAN
TWEAK IT ALONG THE LINE, BUT
THIS IS A COMMITTEE THAT HAS
BROUGHT IN SO THAT THE RESEARCH
IS SUSTAINED IN THE LONG TERM.
THE RESEARCH WILL NOT HAPPEN IN
THE SHORT TERM.
IT'S A LONG-TERM INVESTMENT.
WE HAVE DIGITAL CAMERAS.
IT'S A VERY LONG-TERM
INVESTMENT.
IT DEMANDS A LOT OF INVESTMENT.
BUT WE RECOGNIZE THAT SOME
COUNTRIES CAN'T DO IT FOR MANY
REASONS
THIS IS WHERE WE HAVE TO ROPE
IN
AND ENGAGE AND IT HAS HAPPENED
IN THE U.S.
WE HAVE SEEN PROJECTS, YOU HAVE
THE FACEBOOK, THE GOOGLE,
THEY'RE ALL SOME SOURCE.
THEY NEED TO HAVE THIS
BLUEPRINT
AND INVESTMENT SO THAT THE
SUSTAINED RESEARCH CAPACITY.
THE SECOND POINT YOU MENTION IS
A TRANSLATION.
MAURITIUS OFFICERS A VERY
INTERESTING CASE STUDY.
SINCE I HAVE BECOME PRESIDENT,
I
HAVE SAID THAT OUR DIVERSITY IS
OUR STRENGTH.
IT'S NOT SOCIAL, IT IS NOT
CULTURAL, BUT IT IS ALSO WE ARE
HOME TO THE FOUR GENETIC TYPES.
WE HAVE ALL OF THE FOUR RACES
LIVING THERE.
THIS WAS ONE OF THE PREMISES ON
WHICH I BID MY COMPANY BECAUSE
WE HAD THE DIVERSITY WHICH WAS
UNIQUE AND WE ALSO HAD THE
PEOPLE.
HOW DO YOU MAKE IT WORK?
RECENTLY IN NEW YORK TIMES, A
LOT OF PRODUCTS IN THE FARMER
INDUSTRY FAIL BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN TESTED ON DIVERSE
POPULATIONS
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
CAPITALIZE ON.
WE NEED TO RETHINK OUR SPACE.
WE CAN BE A  BEACON OF PEACE.
IT SHOULD BE RESILIENT IN SPITE
OF OUR DIFFERENCES.
LEARN FROM OUR DIFFERENCES,
EXCHANGE AND ENRICH OURSELVES
AND NOT LET IT BE A DIVIDING
FORCE.
>>> HI, I'M FROM LEBANON
I'M STUDYING SOCIAL POLICIES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INSPIRING
SPEECH.
WE AS WOMEN, WE'RE VERY PROUD
OF
YOU.
MY QUESTION IS, YOU MENTIONED
IN
YOUR SPEECH THAT THE TOP
PRIORITY OF THE GOVERNMENT WAS
TRANSPARENCY.
AS YOU KNOW, THEY PRAISED
MAURITIUS.
WHAT WERE THE MAIN CHALLENGES
FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO SHIFT THE
MIND OF THE INVESTORS, CURRENT
INVESTORS ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
TRANSPARENCY?
YOU MENTIONED CAPSTONE LAST
YEAR, I'M PART OF A TEAM
WORKING
ON A CAPSTONE ON INDIA FOR AN
INVESTMENT IN INDIA, WHAT IS
YOUR PERSONAL OPINION, THE MAIN
CHALLENGE FOR INDIA TO ATTRACT
FOR INVESTMENT WITH REGARD TO
TRANSPARENCY?
>> BE YOU'RE AN INVESTOR YOU
WANT TO INVEST IN CAPITAL X AND
YOU WANT TO HAVE A PROCESS THAT
MAKES SURE THAT YOU GET A
RETURN
ON YOUR INVESTMENT.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT THERE ARE
THESE COUNTRIES, COUNTRY X
WHERE
YOU INVEST HAS A RULE OF LAW.
CONSIDERING YOU'RE NOT HAPPY
THERE, YOU CAN RECOUP YOUR
MONEY.
HAVING SAID THIS, I WOULD BE A
CLICHE, FOR EVERY CORRUPTEE,
THERE IS A CORRUPTER.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT OURSELVES.
ARE WE DOING THINGS RIGHT?
ARE WE ADHERING TO THESE
VALUES?
MOST FAMILIES TELL YOU DO
THINGS
PROPERLY BECAUSE A CORRUPT
ACTION, A CORRUPT PRACTICE IS A
TAX ON THE POOR AND THIS IS
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO BE VERY
MINDFUL OF.
IN EVERY COUNTRY, THERE'S A
STRATEGY BACK TO THE BORING
VALUES, BUT THEY ARE
FUNDAMENTAL
VALUES AND THE NEXT THING YOU
MENTION IS ABOUT CAPITAL
INVESTMENT IN INDIA, WE HAVE
BEEN A GATEWAY FOR A LOT OF
INVESTMENTS IN INDIA AND INDIA
HAS CHANGED THE LAW RECENTLY,
MINDFUL OF THE DYNAMICS GOING
ON.
ONE THING ALSO, WE HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL AND KNOW THAT WE ARE
LIVING IN THE DIGITAL AGE.
WE ARE LIVING IN A TIME WHEN
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE, WHERE
INFORMATION IS INSTANT.
IT IS OUR DUTY, IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO PRESERVE AS
FAR AS POSSIBLE THE
JURISDICTION
AND IT'S DOWN TO EACH
INDIVIDUAL
TO DO THINGS PROPERLY.
I HOPE I HAVE ANSWERED YOUR
QUESTION.
>> I HAD A QUESTION ABOUT
CONTINUING A FOREIGN
INVESTMENT.
THAT'S AN INCREDIBLE JOB.
IT HASN'T YET BROKEN TO THE
SIZE.
THE QUESTION IS HOW TO CONTINUE
TO BRING IN A FOREIGN
INVESTMENT
AND BALANCING AND BRINGING IN
INTERNAL INVESTING AS WELL.
>> WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING OVER
THE PAST FIVE, SIX YEARS IS TO
INCREASE A LOT OF EXCHANGES
WITH
MANY REGIONS IN AFRICA.
BUT, OF COURSE, ALL THIS IS
WORK
IN PROGRESS
WE HAVE TO SEE TO IT THAT IT
MATCHES THE INTERNATIONAL
NORMALS AND THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS.
BUT HAVING SAID THAT, YOU KNOW,
THE INVESTMENT IS HAPPENING.
WE KNOW WE HAVE TO KEEP ON
MODIFYING AND SHOWING THAT WE
DO
BUSINESS PERHAPS DIFFERENTLY
MAYBE WE'LL SEE MORE TRADE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE EUROPEAN
UNION, IT'S 46%.
A HUGE POTENTIAL MARKET, BUT
OUR
JOB IS TO SEE TO IT THAT ALL OF
THE DOCUMENTS, ALL OF THIS,
THEY
ARE IN TUNE WITH WHAT IS GOING
ON AND ALL THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS.
>> HELLO, I'M A FRESHMAN IN
COLUMBIA COLLEGE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SPEECH.
IT WAS VERY ENLIGHTNING.
MY QUESTION HAS TO DO WITH
CORRUPTION.
MY QUESTION IS, WHAT FACTORS
ALLOWS MAURITIUS -- DO YOU SEE
ANTICORRUPTION, WHAT CAN THEY
DO
TO SEE ANTICORRUPTION AS A NORM
AS OPPOSED TO A TREND?
>> MAURITIUS IS A COUNTRY THAT
BECAME INDEPENDENT IN 1968.
BUT I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT
DECISION WE TOOK OVER AND
ABOVE,
THE MAURITIUS STORY HAVING ALL
OF THE SOCIAL PROTECTION, BUT
THE MOST IMPORTANT IS FREE
EDUCATION.
FREE EDUCATION AS WE KNOW IS A
SOCIAL ENABLER.
IT'S A VEHICLE THAT YOU CAN PUT
MESSAGES ACROSS BETTER AND THIS
IS AGAIN SOMETHING WE ARE DOING
AND WE GIVE A LOT OF SUBSIDIES
TO PEOPLE WHO WANT TO DO
CONTINUOUS LEARNING
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO MANY
CHANGES INCLUDING ADDRESSING
CORRUPTION WHICH IS A TAX ON
THE
POOR.
YOU MENTIONED OUR GOOD NUMBERS,
OUR NUMBERS IN TERMS OF THE
RANKING.
BUT YOU KNOW ALL OF THIS
DEPENDS
WHETHER THE GLASS IS HALF FULL
OR HALF EMPTY.
MAYBE WE SHOULD BENCHMARK
OURSELVES TO THE OTHER
COUNTRIES
DOING BETTER.
ALL THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS.
>>> I'M A FRESHMAN AT COLUMBIA
COLLEGE.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORDS TODAY.
THEY WERE THOUGHT PROVOKING AND
ME COMING FROM AN AFRICAN
COUNTRY, I HOLD THE IDEAS YOU
EXPRESS DEARLY.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW TODAY
IS YOUR OPINION ON ALL OF THE
INTERNATIONAL AIDE FLOWING INTO
THE CONTINENT AND WHETHER IT
HAS
A PLACE IN DEVELOPING AFRICA
AND
IF IT LEADS TO SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT.
>> YOU CAN BE CLICHE, YOU CAN
SAY MORE TRADE AND LESS AIDE.
AIDE HAS BEEN USEFUL.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE INTERVENTION
IN WEST AFRICA WITH THE EBOLA
CRISIS, IT HAS HELPED BRING THE
COUNTRY, THE REGION BACK AGAIN
TO THE FOLD.
I THINK IT'S ALSO UP TO US,
NATIONS, AFRICAN NATIONS TO
REALLY TAKE OUR DESTINY IN OUR
HANDS AND INVEST IN OUR OWN
PEOPLE.
WE HAVE TO CREATE THE SPACE.
I THINK MONEY IS GOOD SEED
MONEY.
BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER ACHIEVEMENTS HAVE BEEN
MADE WITH THE HELP OF MONEY, BE
SUSTAINED WITH OUR OWN
CONTRIBUTION.
IF WE WANT TO EDUCATE OUR
PEOPLE, WE HAVE TO PUT OUR
HANDS
IN OUR POCKET.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE MADE
POSSIBLE BY AIDE MONEY ONLY
WE HAVE TO SPEAK TO OURSELVES.
AND WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT WE
INVEST IN OUR PEOPLE.
TO STRESS THE POINT, WE HAVE TO
INVEST IN OUR INSTITUTIONS AND
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO SEE
TO IT THAT YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE
YOURSELF, YOU ASK FOR MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY FROM YOUR
GOVERNMENTS.
>>> GOOD MORNING.
I AM VISITING FROM SHANGHAI,
CHINA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
EXCELLENT SPEECH.
I'M VERY GLAD TO LEARN THAT
GREAT PROGRESS IN YOUR COUNTRY
IN SCIENCE, TECHNOLOGY AND
INNOVATION, I HAVE TWO REQUEST
IS
COMPARED TO THE ANOTHER ISLAND
COUNTRY, DEPENDING MUCH ON
ECONOMICS, WHAT ADVANTAGE DOES
YOUR COUNTRY HAVE AND THE
SECOND QUESTION IS, I WANT TO
KNOW WHAT
IS YOUR OPINION ON THESE?
THANK YOU.
>> THE COUNTRY YOU MENTIONING?
>> CAN YOU REPEAT THE QUESTION.
>> COMPARED, ANOTHER ISLAND
COUNTRY, DEPENDING MUCH ON
TOURISM ECONOMIC, WHAT KIND OF
ADVANTAGE DOES YOUR COUNTRY
HAVE?
>> TOURISM IS ONE PILLAR ON THE
ECONOMY OF MAURITIUS.
BUT YOU WOULD BE SURPRISED IF I
WOULD TO TELL YOU THAT TOURISM
COUNTS FOR 10 POINTS ON THE
ECONOMY OF A COUNTRY
TOURISM, IT'S A PRODUCT THAT
NEEDS TO BE INNOVATED ALL
ALONG.
WHAT DO WITH I DO WHEN WE OFFER
A TOURISM PACKAGE?
WE SELL DREAMS.
WE DO IT, WE CREATE AN IMAGE
AROUND THIS.
BUT HAVING SAID THIS, WHEN THE
TOURISTS REACHES OUR SHORES,
IT'S OUR DOWNTOWN TO BE SURE
THAT THE TOURIST IS READY FOR
MONEY AND WE DELIVER ON THE
PROMISES WE'VE MADE.
A COUNTRY I CAN'T COMMENT ON
ANOTHER COUNTRY, JUST FOR
COMPARISON, IT'S A COUNTRY THAT
DEPENDS ON TOURISM.
NOW, WITH CLIMATE CHANGE, MAYBE
THERE WILL BE A RETHINKING
PROCESS THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
VERY, VERY FAST.
THESE REGIONS WITH THE OCEAN
AND
THE RISE OF SEA LEVEL.
IT'S GOING TO BE BE A PROBLEM
TO
THE REGION.
WE'RE ALSO BEING IMPACTED AND
WE
ARE WITNESSES MORE SEVERE
STORMS, YOU JUST SEEN TWO IN
THE
CARIBBEAN RECENTLY, BUT NOBODY
IS SPARED FROM THIS NATURAL
ACTIVITY.
TOURISM IS ONE BUT WE HAVE TO
KEEP ON ECONOMY SO THAT WHEN
THE
DISASTER STRIKES, THE ECONOMY
IS
NOT FLAT OUT.
AND SECOND ONE IS ABOUT THE
TIES, WE HAVE LINKS WITH THE
COUNTRY, OUR FOREIGN POLICY IS
THAT WE'RE FRIENDS TO ALL AND
ENEMIES TO NONE.
THAT'S IT.
>> HI.
I'M A STUDENT, A GRADUATE
STUDENT, MASTER STUDENT OF
SUSTAINABILITY MANAGEMENT.
ARE YOU SATISFIED BY THE
SUSTAINABLE PROGRAMS IN
MAURITIUS?
>> IF NOT, WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SEE THEM DO FURTHER?
>> THEY CONTRIBUTE ABOUT 2% OF
THE GROSS, AGAIN, IT'S THE
INCOME.
BUT IT'S THE NET INCOME.
BUT TALKING ABOUT THE
CONTRIBUTE
IS ALREADY SOMETHING.
AND GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN TRYING
TO PUT GUIDELINES TO ENSURE
THAT
THOSE WHO ARE MOST DESERVING,
THEY BENEFIT.
BUT LIKE ANYTHING ELSE, IS IT
SUFFICIENT?
IS THE GLASS HALF FULL OR HALF
EMPTY?
I THINK WE CAN STILL DO MUCH
MORE.
THOSE WHO ARE MORE DESERVING,
WE
TARGET THEM MORE SO THEIR
LIVELIHOODS GET IMPROVED AND WE
COME OUT A STRONGER SOCIETY.
WE HAVE REDUCED THE GAP IN THE
HAVES AND THE HAVE NOTES
THANK YOU.
>> WE CAN ONLY TAKE ONE MORE
QUESTION
SO YOU WILL BE THE LAST, SO
MAKE
IT GOOD.
>> THAT'S A LOT OF PRESSURE.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE TAKEOFF OF
MOBILE BANKING IN KENYA.
MY QUESTION IS THREEFOLD, WHAT
YOU FELT ABOUT THE REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT IN KENYA THAT
ALLOWED MOBILE BANKING TO TAKE
OFF?
DO YOU FEEL A TREND IS ON THE
WAY OR HAPPENING IN MAURITIUS
AND IF NOT, WHERE DO YOU SEE IS
THE FUTURE OF TECHNOLOGY AND
FINANCIAL TECHNOLOGY IN
MAURITIUS?
>> I THINK MAURITIUS HAS BEEN
REVOLUTIONARY.
IT HAS MADE SO MANY PEOPLE WHO
NEVER HAD BANK ACCOUNTS CAN DO
THE TRANSACTIONS ON THEIR
PHONE.
NOW YOU CAN ALSO ASK THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE PROPERTY,
WILL THIS BENEFIT AFRICA, YOU
CAN CHECK IT OUT.
BUT WE HAVE THE EQUIVALENT OF
THIS PLATFORM NOW WHERE WE CAN
DO TRANSFERS, FINANCIAL
TRANSFERS
THE GOVERNMENT IS VERY KEEN ON
FINANCIAL TECHNOLOGIES AND WE
HAD A WORKSHOP AND LOOKING AT
THE ENVIRONMENT TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN
WE REALIZE THAT SO MUCH CAN BE
DONE AND SO MUCH CAN BE GAINED
THROUGH THIS TECHNOLOGY.
AGAIN, IT CAN CONNECT YOU TO
THE
AUTHORITIES WHO CAN HAVE MUCH
MORE TO TELL YOU IN TERMS OF
THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY NEAR
MAURITIUS.
>> THANK YOU.
BEFORE I THANK THE PRESIDENT
FOR
HER RASHES, I WOULD LIKE TO
A NUMBER.
CULTURE IS A SOURCE OF
INSPIRATION.
THAT SAYS A LOT.
BRAIN CIRCULATION, I LIKE THAT.
WE'RE ALL ONE.
WE CAN GO AWAY, BUT WE'RE STILL
PART OF THE WHOLE.
CURIOSITY AND RESEARCH VERSES
BIG FARMER.
WE NEED THE GOVERNMENT.
ONE THAT I HOPE THE MESSAGE
GOES
TO WASHINGTON D.C., OUR
DIVERSITY IS OUR STRENGTH.
SO IS OURS
WE CAN LEARN FROM OUR
DIFFERENCES
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANTED A
POLITICAL MESSAGE, BUT YOU GAVE
ONE.
FREE EDUCATION IS THE GROUND
WORK.
WHAT WE DO WITH IT IS ANOTHER.
WITHOUT IT WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYTHING.
MONEY IS ONLY SEED MONEY, IT'S
THE BEGINNING AND NOT THE END.
INVEST IN PEOPLE.
IT'S THE SAME, EDUCATE.
SHE'S GIVEN A LOT OF FOOD FOR
THOUGHT.
IT'S INSPIRATIONAL.
STUDENTS HAVE DONE WELL BY
ASKING GOOD QUESTIONS
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
AND COME BACK.
PLEASE
[APPLAUSE]